your co-star Larry David is on Broadway
or was on Broadway did you go and see
him when he's on Broadway course I did I
had to support the man he's a good
friend of mine sugar oh but I'm not
support Larry baby you know I went there
and I want to miss Ross support him the
right way so I got here I put my best on
my best theater tire you know I haven't
let cross like this okay yeah shoes like
this huh I'm a little kid hello Caine a
little best little top hat little head
about my stairs your momma caught my eye
like this but a moustache on did you
really do that how do you think people
dress when they go to the theater King
and have located that lean forward yeah
very I'm leaning forward towards the
stage yes that's how I look my monocle
my I like this that's how it did like
the monopoly guy that's how I looked
yeah tall top hat on like this okay so
your your dress like that did Larry
notice you while he was doing the show
of course he's noticed me yeah who could
not notice this outfit right here that's
classy theater attire
yeah I'm leaning forward very very
toward the stage like this
uh-huh he stops in the middle of show
say JB what the hell are you doing I
said what does it mean what the hell I'm
doing this is how people dress when they
go to the theater
did he did they try and get rid of you
for disturbing the show of course they
did I'm sitting on a damn idiot
okay here's my question Larry David quit
that show that's a fact he quit that
show not long after you went and saw it
this is a true story do you think he
quit because you showed up and threw him
off his game
of course he quit because I sold up I'm
sitting there with pointed shoes on a
monocle my damn my vest door I have
about 1,000 a top hat on
of course he quit I told my was coming
back for the whole weekend I got back
the next day he wasn't there he didn't
show up right hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please